cuando aprendieron cálculo por primera
vez aprendieron que la derivada de
alguna función
efe podría ser escrita como f prima de x
bueno de que hay muchas formas en las
que podemos escribir esto pero deseamos
que f prima tx es el límite cuando delta
de x tiende a cero de f de x más delta
de x y a esto le quitábamos fx y todo
esto lo dividimos entre delta de x y
aprendieron varias notaciones para esto
por ejemplo sabemos que si que es igual
a fx entonces podemos escribir a efe
prima de x como y prima o la podríamos
ver como la derivada de con respecto x
lo cual es exactamente igual que la
derivada de f con respecto a x porque
que es igual a nuestra función pero
después especialmente cuando empezamos a
entrar en ecuaciones diferenciales ven
que la gente comienza a manejar esto
son como una expresión algebraica real
por ejemplo aprenderán o podría ser que
ya lo vieron que si estamos tratando de
resolver la siguiente ecuación
diferencial la derivada de con respecto
a x igual hay quien entonces la tasa de
cambio de que con respecto a x es igual
al valor de 10 es lo que me dice esta
expresión y de hecho es una de las
ecuaciones diferenciales más básicas que
podrían resolver verán para esto
aplicamos la siguiente técnica donde en
general decimos bien sólo vamos a
multiplicar de ambos lados por de x solo
manejando de x como si fuera una
expresión algebraica entonces
multiplicarían de ambos lados por de x y
luego estas de x se cancelarían
algebraica mente y entonces nos
quedaríamos que de james es igual a gem
x
x y bueno después dicen ahora vamos a
dividir de ambos lados entre james lo
cual es una cosa razonable de hacer ya
que james es una expresión algebraica
así que se dividen de ambos lados entre
james y obtienen que uno entre james x
de james es igual a de x y luego amigos
integran de ambos lados para encontrar
una solución general para esta ecuación
diferencial y ya está pero mi objetivo
aquí en este vídeo no es pensar en cómo
resolver esta ecuación diferencial lo
que quiero hacer es pensar en esta
noción de usar lo que llamamos
diferenciales es decir una de equis o
una de james y que veas que pueden ser
manejados de una manera deje práctica
donde puedo simplemente multiplicar
ambos lados por de x o de james o
dividir de ambos lados entre de x o de
gemma y normalmente no digo esto pero el
rigor que necesitan para mostrar que
esto se puede hacer y que es correcto no
es algo fácil de decir y entonces quiero
que te quede claro que esto es bastante
intuitivo
pero no es muy matemáticamente riguroso
ahora lo que sí es que es una
herramienta bastante útil para nosotros
para encontrar las soluciones este tipo
de ecuaciones y conceptualmente la forma
en la que planteó una de james o un de
equis esquema de james es un cambio muy
pequeño en james en respuesta a un
cambio muy pequeño en x de x y esto es
esencialmente lo que la definición del
límite nos está diciendo especialmente
cuando delta de x se aproxima a 0 a
tener un cambio muy pequeño en x de x y
luego vamos a tener acá arriba un cambio
resultante bien muy pequeño de james
entonces ésta podría ser una manera para
sentirse un poco mejor y en realidad
esta es una de las justificaciones para
este tipo de notación cuál es el cambio
muy pequeño en james para un cambio muy
pequeño en x lo cual nos está dando el
sentido de cuál es el valor limitante de
la pendiente es decir
cuando pasamos de la pendiente de la
recta secante hacia la pendiente de una
recta tangente y si lo ven de esta
manera podrán sentirse un poco mejor
usando estos diferenciales y manipulando
los algebraica mente así que el gran
panorama es utilizar esta técnica que
muchas veces verán en las clases de
introducción a las ecuaciones
diferenciales en las clases de
introducción al cálculo multi variable y
en las clases de introducción al cálculo
pero no es muy matemáticamente riguroso
manejar diferenciales como expresiones
algebraicas pero a pesar de que no es
muy matemáticamente riguroso podemos
hacerlo a discreción y de esta manera
usarlo para que no sea útil ahora a
medida de que se vuelven más
sofisticados en sus matemáticas hay
definiciones rigurosas de un diferencial
donde pueden obtener un mejor sentido
sobre cuando es matemáticamente riguroso
usar de esta manera las diferenciales
como expresiones algebraicas y cuando no
pero aquí el objetivo completo
el vídeo es si tuvieron un pequeño
sentimiento extraño multiplicando de
ambos lados por de equis o dividiendo de
ambos lados entre de james o de equis su
sentimiento estaba justificado
matemáticamente ya que no es una cosa
muy rigurosa de hacer al menos hasta que
tengan más rigor detrás pero les diremos
que si son estudiantes de una clase
introducción es una cosa razonable de
hacer mientras exploran y manipulan
algunas de estas ecuaciones
diferenciales básicas